before projection is an exhibition that
highlights what I think is a somewhat
underappreciated moment and video art
which our monitor sculptures sculptures
using the television set the boxy
monitor that were made from the late 70s
until the 1990s and one of the
interesting things is that in the 1990s
video projection comes into the gallery
space and I think we've all seen large
immersive cinematic projections and when
that form became standard a lot of the
earlier video art kind of went into
storage and really hasn't been taken out
again and I felt for a really long time
in my previous museum jobs that it some
of these works really deserve to be
reconsidered for a number of reasons I
think they function in many ways quite
differently from a cinematic projection
they really certain themselves in
three-dimensional space and in sculpture
which i think is something that you can
see clearly when looking at the works
what I loved about the monitor was that
it was this magic box that you could
place anywhere in space and you could
build things it was like a kid's set of
building blocks you could create an
architectural space you could create a
sculptural space you could create a
space for people to walk into for them
to walk around as you can see from all
these pieces in this show you can do all
of those different things and I found
that to be fantastic I think when you
look at these works it's it's clear the
monitor itself has this very clear sort
of material three-dimensional presence
unlike a flat screen on the wall which
is a picture on the wall or a projection
which tends to become it looks of a much
larger immersive environment so on the
one end I think a lot of these works are
located more in the white cube of the
gallery it's not proscenium art it's not
a mersive art a lot of them you can see
in the round like more traditional
sculpture you can walk around so they do
kind of they really do participate and
they function in similar ways as more
traditional forms of sculpture
the video want a story cigar Peter
mukesh card machine Dickson - electrons
and buildest survived and electronic
speech that's us feel free inclined
answer Titan Sue's Amman bus Jewish
d-formed the video about autumn
oportunidad the other arguments I was
trying to make with each with the show
is to kind of reconsider these kind of
works and put them more fully into the
narrative between very early video art
which has been getting a lot of critical
and curatorial attention and then
cinematic projection in the 1990s and
kind of look at this moment and think
about it both in relationship to the
Moving Image in what these works do but
also to kind of claim the relevance of
this kind of work in relationship to
sculpture in more traditional mediums in
general
[Music]
[Music]
you